I'm saying here's the speak up I can now
announce the result of today's recorded
votes on nations relating to the United
Kingdom's withdrawal from and future
relationship with the European Union in
respect of mr. Baran's motion be
brackets No Deal the eyes were 160 the
nose were 400 so the nose habit in
respect of mr. Nicolas polls motion de
common market 2.0 the eyes were 188 the
nose were 283 so the noes have it
in respect of George Eustace his motion
H after an EE
a the eyes were 65 the nose were 377 so
the nose habit in respect of mr. Kenneth
Clark's motion Jay customs union the
eyes were 264 the nose were 272
no his habit in respect of the leader of
the opposition's motion Kay Labor's
alternative plan the eyes were 237 the
nose were 307 in respect of Joanna
Terry's motion L a revocation to avoid
New Deal the eyes were 184 the nose were
293 so the noes have it in respect of
day Margaret Beckett's motion M
confirmatory public vote the eyes were
268 the nose were 295
[Applause]
[Music]
in respect mr. Marcus fishes motion Oh
contingent preferential arrangements the
eyes were 139 the nose were 422 so the
noes have it
[Applause]
I'm finishing I'm finishing my stable
let him require any help from the
government chief with the list showing
how honorable he learns he should listen
he'll learn the lish showing how
honorable and right honourable members
voted will be published in the usual way
on Commons boat and website and in hand
sir